hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara Jessa and tonight I
went and saw crazy rich Asians when I
first saw the trailer for this film it
kind of looked like the Asian version of
Fifty Shades of Grey there was a lot of
like topless hot dudes and money being
thrown around and it's just an innocent
girl who doesn't know what she's getting
herself into and I was honestly pretty
skeptical about it then reviews started
coming out and it's got like a 95
percent on Rotten Tomatoes right now so
I went into expecting to really enjoy it
and it did not disappoint this was a
feel-good incredibly written character
driven movie that was just delightful I
giggled throughout the whole thing but
those like delightful giggles where
you're just like happy to be
experiencing what you're experiencing
it's my okay my camera's just slowly
tilting what's going on there but why
why are you tilting away from me hello
come back my god yes good okay what most
impressed me about this film were the
characters I was so invested in all of
these stories the main story is about
our lead character Rachel who has fallen
in love with a young who it's a very
rich family and she doesn't have a clue
about it and so she's kind of just
dropped into this world of you know
years 100-year old traditions and she is
just trying to catch up and fit in as
much as possible there's also other
stories going on the best one I think
being this side story of the cousin
Astrid whose husband is spoilers I guess
husband is cheating on her and there's
also just some really lovely things
going on with Rachel's mother and the
entire young family and Rachel's friend
from college and every single character
that you interact with and you meet is
so well written and developed and
you love all of them I was worried that
this was going to be I think it could
have easily felt like a cheesy just way
to throw diversity into a chick flick
film and it didn't feel like that it
felt so just full of life and just
lovely uh romantic moments but gorgeous
shots this soundtrack is just awesome
very cool badass beautiful fun fresh
this whole thing was just very
refreshing if that makes any sense the
beginning starts off and there's really
nice animation there's some lettering
throughout that feels very nostalgic and
kind of 70s ish there's a lot of throws
to 70s in this film the comedy stands
out above all else it's so new and like
refreshing is the word that I keep
wanting to come back to it's hilarious
laugh out loud funny this film has been
out for a few days I didn't see the
first showing of it and the audience it
was jam-packed so that's you know saying
something and also they were like
clapping at things that were happening
and like snapping when certain things
were happening and just very invested
and it's because the comedy was so
spot-on and none of it fell flat and it
was just wow so engaging there's a lot
of tense moments especially with Rachel
and the mother and you have some moments
of like awkwardness and tension but it
still remains in this light and fun and
easy to watch realm which is great there
weren't any like oh like shrugging
through moments which is nice I wrote it
makes you squirm in your seat with the
sex appeal also this film has there's
some sexy moments there is one scene
where God I forget the the guy's name
John Justin
Nick Nick there's a scene where Rachel
and Nick are attending a wedding and
you're so invested in the bride and
groom but so much more than that there's
this moment between Nick and Rachel
where they're just connecting with their
eyes cuz they're across the way and
they're mouthing that they love each
other and she's crying and it's ah it's
so stunning and the emotion that you
feel for these characters is killer
okay a chick flick for sure but it's on
the levels of one of the greats
you want to feel good watch crazy rich
Asians and that should be the slogan of
the film crazy rich Asian do you want to
feel good watch this shit and it's like
feel good and that's what like you want
out of going to the theater at least
that's what I want
shouldn't speak for everyone I speak for
the trees I am The Lorax there's moments
throughout this film where rachel is
realizing certain things about what her
life has been about what her life could
be about just her going on this ride of
finding out who Nick's family is and who
Nick really is she doesn't know that he
is part of this just a huge dynasty of
tons of money and her finding out who
the family is is hilarious
her kind of finding out what her life
could be is stressful her getting
bullied for being who she is and who
she's with is you know a lot and she
sees his childhood home for the first
time and the locations and the sets in
this film are incredible but
specifically the young estate is
stunning and elaborate and detailed and
her meeting everyone is super awkward
and her meeting the grandmother is like
a saving grace the grandma is like a
shining star and this for most of the
film and the mom is just a
tension-filled wreck for most of the
film I just love the resolve that you
get with the mom that it's
not perfect ever and it never will be
but there's a reconciliation there
that's lovely they have this common
bonding her and the mother that is so
hard for the mom to get over but it's
just it's really lovely for her there's
really great pacing also with the film
that you get with her going to visit the
family her meeting the family her going
to a bachelorette party while Nick is
out of bachelor party then heading to
the wedding of those parties and then
her you know kind of wrapping up her
time there and thinking maybe this isn't
going to work out I love the different
chapters of this film and they're all so
fun and different and funny friend
rachel is so funny oh my god the casting
and the acting in this film are just
spot-on perfect this friend is so good
and the friends family it may be even
better just such a good and important
role in this film the chick there friend
has a line which says chickens are
bitches dude bok-bok bitch the entire
theatre was clapping I wrote oh my god
there's a Princess Diaries makeover
scene but with contemporary comedy
that's all I want it's just a
contemporary version of The Princess
Diaries makeover scene so thank you for
that crazy-rich agents thank you all in
all I mean it was just it was just super
delightful it was really fun I'm
definitely gonna rewatch it and also
there's something to be said about the
audience that I was with was like 90%
asian humans and I there's just
something huge to be said about that
that representation is so important and
we're in a time of film where I think
producers and directors and filmmakers
are starting to get that that's what we
want in film is just different also the
previews that I got before this film
were the most diverse set of previews
I've ever seen before a film ever
and it was delightful and and so it was
really nice to see a film that was full
of diversity that was also just a slam
dunk it was so good and so entertaining
and I'm so glad for everyone involved
with it
what were their previous searching that
looks excellent yes yes Asian
representation operation final looks
horrifying incredible yes killing Nazis
what men want yes
gender swapping the hate you give yes
truth night school yes Tiffany Haddish a
stars born yes Lady Gaga's screaming
with that voice and small foot it's
pretty men I guess I loved this I super
recommend it definitely go watch it
thank you so much for watching I'm not
really sure what next week holds but
hopefully it's as good as this was
because this was an absolute delight I
really needed just like a feel-good
triumphant lovely film and this is
totally what that was thank you for
watching and I will see you guys next
week
Bok Bob bitch
[Music]
you